laying the groundwork for the most
ambitious transport project in the UK's
recent history after years of delay
finally a timetable to deliver hs2 but
it comes at an estimated cost of more
than a hundred and twenty seven billion
dollars the cabinet has given high speed
rail the green signal we are going to
get this done and to ensure that we do
so without further blowouts or either
cost or schedule we are today taking
decisive action to restore discipline to
the program hs2 have been in doubt after
a review prompted by the rocketing costs
now it should transform parts of
Britain's tired and overcrowded railway
network cutting the journey time from
London to Birmingham to just 45 minutes
well this site will be completely
transformed over the next six years this
will be the northern terminus for phase
one of this project and the station will
stretch from where the excavator is
following the distance to where I'm
standing
HS to has been a political sore point
some of Forest Johnson's own party don't
want it opponent site spiraling costs
and say the money should have been spent
on upgrading the current network phase
worm will improve travel links between
London and Birmingham and the second
part will provide better links to parts
of the north of England business as
invested in the Midlands on the promise
of more interconnectivity well it's
gonna make the country physically a lot
smaller but it will help change the
mentality that that London doesn't stop
at the Outer Ring Road so in the future
people will be able to get from London
to where we are faster than they can get
from South London to North London and
those people are going to be candidates
for jobs that were trying to hire they
could be client clients that were trying
to sell to hs2 aims to be the most
sustainable high-speed railway in the
world yet it will cut through parts of
the English countryside destroying
ancient woodland and other wildlife
habitats in woods the 40-minute drive
from Birmingham people call themselves
protectors of the woodland
rather than protesters Boris Johnson has
almost declared war on the English
countryside and I think people are going
to fight for every scrap of ancient
woodland that they can hs2 has been on
the cards for more than a decade many
wanted this project to stall yet the
government is pushing ahead with the
promise of economic development in the
north
Emma Haywood al-jazeera central England